i thought that was photoshopped no dude
those are real tips
those are i would love to have titties i
think you would i would love it yeah i
would suck my to my tits just no let me
ask you something about tits yeah
oppressed you're asking him and not me
well you have practiced
let me ask you about um human breasts
okay
and i and i'm gonna ask some questions
so when i'm
let's say i have human breasts you have
was a woman
no i was like a female breast okay
and i want milk can i just suck it out
of there any time i want to or no no
what do we know i've seen women on
youtube suck their own breasts
i'm sorry but you mean to say that i can
just produce milk on my own right now no
if you have a baby yeah oh is that you
have to have a baby well and also you it
doesn't even really really come out only
colostrum comes out the first time we
know about that
but it means it's like it's like a
feedback loop so the baby okay can i
explain how it goes i'm confused yeah i
explain it please so it's not until the
actual the baby starts to suckle
that it sends a signal to the brain
and the oc and your brain releases
oxytocin and then all of a sudden you
start it will um it will it's a catalyst
for multiple projections so if i make my
blips like a baby's lips and i go gaga
google and i suck my own no just be real
okay right because you're you know the
will my will my breasts be able to
realize that it's an actor acting like a
baby or it's a real baby oh no you can
just suck anyone can suck well then that
don't okay there we go so you want to be
a wet nurse
you know like back in the day like
really rich um monarchs they didn't want
they had to a country to rule so they'd
be like look i don't want to breastfeed
why don't we just have a woman who's
already breastfeeding a baby to
breastfeed all my kids that's a job
that's a job a wet nurse yes
yeah
they still do because i think that
i mean now
you that you can get because some women
don't produce milk as easily so you can
buy
breast milk from other women who are who
pump a lot who are really good um milk
producers i have a question you might
have to edit this
or not or not you might have to edit
this out or not but it's a science
question right all right it's a science
question
so i let's say um
kalila right we have a baby sure and
clyde is breastfeeding the baby okay
right but right before right the baby
latches on to the breast right i slip in
my dick where and where
he's mouth and the baby latches onto my
head of my penis is that illegal
[Laughter]
science
is that illegal is it illegal are you
doing it with intention to slip it in a